foreign
let's go to Annie in Tampa Florida
what's up Annie
I just found
out late last week that my husband owes
uh over a hundred thousand dollars on
to the IRS and to the Department of
Revenue and I have no idea what to do
ouch how'd you find out
um well the tax
um it's always been filed um married but
separately we've only been married a
little bit over five years and so there
were some you know not doing the taxes
not doing not filing not filing finally
they are got filed and
um the the total just was presented to
us late last week does that include any
late fees penalties
yeah it's a whole Smorgasbord of a lot
of things oh so what made you guys
ignore it for a few years
um it was
where I um
I would just you know kind of keep
asking can we please get this done
please get this done please get this
done
um and you'd ask your husband like hey
have you filed taxes yet
mine are mine are all filed separately
and and all taken care of but he never
filed for how many years
uh for a total of
um about six years yeah so it's been my
experience in this in these moments
Annie over the years that there's two
things going on number one you are
pissed off
it's a one of the foundations of doing
business is paying taxes and taking care
of your business and my guess is he
doesn't take care of his business in
other areas is that fair
um I have to say that I've really
processed through a lot of this and done
a lot of praying with it so I'm really
I'm past that okay um praise God and I'm
at a place where I'm very grateful that
they finally did get filed and processed
and now we just I'm talking to so many
so many so-called experts who are
telling us to do all kinds of different
things try to reach out to The Experts
I'm sorry did you reach out to these
experts
um it was it was really both of us right
now I just I just finished school and so
I am currently not working I'm studying
for a big exam
and so he's working two jobs he is an
exceptionally hard worker
what does he make what's the household
income currently
right now it's about 52 maybe 53 with
some overtime
um he's a W-2 employee at this point and
that's with both jobs
um no no I'm sorry I'm sorry A lot has
changed
with the side jobs
um probably an extra at this time
there's no there's no exercise jobs
right now okay and let's assume you
passed your exam what are you going to
be bringing home
um somewhere around around 60 60 60 to
65. okay so we'll be at six figures
pretty soon
yeah because we need to increase the
shovel ASAP and this IRS debt is going
to go to the top of your debt snowball
and it's going to be the one thing you
focus on probably for the next few years
okay and we're not going to get no
schemes no hey if you just do this or
they they're not even allowed to do that
there's going to be people on YouTube
get off listen to any expert that tries
to sell you a shortcut here none there
is no shortcut here the only way to get
rid of it is to get rid of it and that
means paying it off incrementally so you
guys need to get in touch with the IRS
and get on a clear communication get on
a payment plan where they know exactly
what you guys are doing how much you're
paying every single month so that we get
a game plan and if you don't already
have a tax Pro in your corner you got to
connect with one you can do that
Ramsay's ramseysolutions.com they can
also help you navigate this and they may
have some better strategies to attack
this
okay one quick question for you
right up against the clock go real quick
we're hearing from a lot of people that
we should go into hard
to analyze if go stop listening no don't
go to hardship you're not in a hardship
you just didn't do your you didn't pay
taxes for five years you're not a
hardship you got the money and you're
about to you've got jobs you've got work
don't go into hardship get with the tax
Pro and get this thing paid off and it's
gonna really be tough no shortcuts no
games never be silent again Annie you
were silent for too long and something
in the back of your head knew it never
again